mad to think anyone can survive a crash
like this never mind four children a
baby among them this story has gripped
Colombia for weeks it is one of survival
but also of trauma
the children survived in this dense
jungle for 40 days completely alone the
bodies of the adults they'd been
traveling with were found near the
plane's wreckage and even that was weeks
after the crash
search teams found Clues Footprints
nappies and bits of half-eaten fruit
they dropped food boxes into the forest
hoping the children might find them and
speakers bled out a message from their
Grandma stay put she told them
then this last night all four found
alive
they had to be hauled up into
helicopters that's how dense this jungle
is
just watch this picture for a bit and
think about this the children are aged
13 9 4 and a baby of just 11 months old
no wonder everyone wants to make
celebrations personal
it's my daughter's 15th birthday
tomorrow and what a great gift this is
to her a great gift for Colombia this is
a gift from life and it shows that our
children were taken care of by the
jungle
now it is time for them to be taken care
of by their country this Commander was
in charge of the search
there was immense joy in their eyes he
says and Promises they'll get the best
care in the country's military hospitals
no doubt there'll be a nation waiting to
welcome them when they're finally home
Sadia Chaudhary Sky News